time and time again we've seen how oil
can transform an entire country just a
hundred years ago for example the middle
east was more or less just a desert
wasteland but today many of these
countries have become more modern than
even western countries i mean when your
police are using lamborghinis and
mercedes for patrol clearly you've got
money but ironically a few of the
countries with the most amount of oil in
the entire world don't actually benefit
from it all that much one of these
countries is canada which has 170
billion barrels of oil this makes them
the country with the third largest oil
reserves in the entire world the only
countries that have more oil are saudi
arabia and venezuela saudi arabia
literally has a 2 trillion oil company
so clearly they're using their resources
to the max
meanwhile venezuela is a third world
country filled with hyperinflation and
corruption so it's not surprising that
they haven't leveraged their resources
but what about canada
canada is a well-respected western
country with plenty of intelligent and
ambitious people yet before the
pandemics create up oil prices oil and
gas only accounted for 128 billion worth
of canada's gdp for perspective there
were years where saudi aramco's profits
alone were nearly 128 billion dollars so
why doesn't canada exploit their
gigantic oil reserves
one of the biggest challenges that
canada has faced in terms of oil is
competing in the global market you see
it there are several different types of
oil and not all oils are created equal
onshore middle eastern oil for example
is one of the easiest to extract and
refine meanwhile the type of oil canada
has oil sands is one of the hardest to
extract and refine the reason for this
is that oil sands aren't even a liquid
form of oil oil sands are actually a
combination of oil sand clay and water
that create this tar-like substance so
you can't just set up a bunch of oil
pumps and ride these to the moon
instead you have to engage in one of two
complex mining and separation processes
for deposits found on the surface the
oil sands first have to be strip mined
then they have to be run through hot
water to isolate a substance called the
bitumen and from there you have to
convert the bitumen into oil this
process itself is already quite complex
and expensive but the worst part is that
this process can only be applied to
land-based deposits and 80 of oil sands
are not land-based usually the majority
of oil sands are buried more than 75
meters under the ground which requires
institute production this is when you
pump a bunch of hot steam into the
ground to separate the bitumen from the
oil sands from there an extraction well
will collect isolated bitumen which can
then be converted into crude oil as you
would guess thanks to the complexity of
this process all sand production is
naturally way more expensive than
traditional oil drilling but that's just
the first problem for canada given that
canada is a developed western country
they actually have standards when it
comes to wages and working conditions in
alberta for example the average wage for
oil and gas workers is 36.52 cents per
hour which works out to roughly 75 000
canadian dollars per year even if we
look at the lowest five percent of oil
workers in alberta they're created 15
canadian dollars per hour or 31 200
canadian dollars per year
in terms of u.s dollars this is
equivalent to roughly 24 000 per year
most westerners probably wouldn't
classify this as a high salary per se
but compared to saudi arabian standards
this is insanely high the average labor
in saudi arabia only make 36 thousand
reals per year or about 9 500 per year
this means that saudi aramco can hire
two and half workers for every employee
alberta hires
also i suspect that alberta likely has
better benefits and fewer working hours
per week so the ratio is even more
skewed in saudi arabia's favor
considering all of this it's simply
impossible for canada to compete in
terms of price and this is why canadian
oil is the most expensive in the world
the average barrel of oil from canada
has a break-even cost of 74 per barrel
meanwhile the average barrel of oil from
the middle east has a break-even cost of
just 29 per barrel with these numbers
it's not even a competition canada would
have to lose 45 per barrel just to match
middle eastern prices meanwhile the
middle east only has to lose 29 per
barrel to offer their oil for free with
such a massive pricing disadvantage it's
no wonder why canada's oil industry
isn't that lucrative
while canada can never reach their
profit margins reached by the middle
east this doesn't mean that they can
never turn a profit you see oil prices
are often times way higher than 74
dollars per barrel between 2004 and 2014
for example oil prices were regularly
over 100 per barrel so canada had plenty
of time to run a profitable operation
but this never really came to fruition
due to their location the middle east is
literally located in the perfect place
to serve a global market on one side
they have asia on another side they have
europe on yet another side they have
africa and on their last side they have
the ocean this gives them a massive
advantage when it comes to building
robust freight networks trucking
networks railroads pipelines and so on
meanwhile canada has the united states
and that's pretty much it if they want
to export oil to any other country their
only option is to use the sea and canada
has basically completely neglected this
option given that 99 of their oil ends
up in the north american market honestly
there doesn't seem to be any clear
reason as to why they haven't grown
their freight operation the main
bottleneck seems to be that their oil
infrastructure is heavily underdeveloped
which has made it extremely difficult to
transport oil from alberta to the
pacific coast there have been a few
projects that have attempted to solve
this issue but more times than not these
projects were plagued with issues and
setbacks take the trans mountain
pipeline for example this project was
designed to help transport oil from
alberta to the coast of british columbia
and it was commissioned way back in 1951
work on this project progressed pretty
quickly and the canadians had the
pipeline up and running by 1953
but to this day this pipeline is the
only pipeline that connects these two
areas for nearly 10 years now canada has
been trying to add a parallel pipeline
to this project but due to politics and
environmentalists this project has been
constantly delayed the latest delay has
pushed the completion date into q3 of
2023 but who knows if that'll actually
play out in the meantime canada's oil
industry is basically 100 dependent on
the us fortunately the us is the world's
largest oil consumer so canada has
plenty of demand for the oil
but this also puts them in a super
awkward position
the us is well aware that they can
singlehandedly make or break canada's
oil industry so they're not exactly
motivated to play nice in fact they
prefer to essentially blackmail canada
into giving them a significant discount
of up to twenty dollars per barrel
factoring in this discount canada's
break-even price for oil isn't just 74
dollars per barrel but more like 94 per
barrel
really they need oil to be over 100 per
barrel to have any shot at making a
profit hopefully the trans mountain
expansion project will be completed soon
and canada can start exploring to asia
as well
but in the meantime canada is not only
cursed by the type of their oil but also
by their location and dependence on the
us
at this point you might be thinking that
things can't get any worse for canada
but the reality is that they can and
they have
aside from having to fight this massive
uphill battles with oil sands and their
location canada also has to put up a
serious fight with environmentalists
now it's natural for any fossil fuel
based operation to gain some opposition
but oil sands garner especially high
opposition because they're especially
harmful to the environment you see it
the process of converting oil sands to
usable oil is not only a long expensive
and complex process but also a water and
energy-intensive process
to make things worse the process does
not exactly release the kindness
byproducts either
in fact oils and extraction it emits up
to three times more global warming
pollution than traditional oil
extraction and it's not just oil based
pollution either oil sand production it
not only depletes fresh water sources
but it also creates gigantic ponds of
toxic waste considering this it's not
surprising that environmentalists are
all over this
in fact environmentalists are one of the
main reasons that the trans mountain
expansion project has had so many delays
they argued that the original pipeline
itself is already extremely destructive
so it makes no sense to build yet
another pipeline and honestly they do
have a point since 1961 trans mountain
has reported 84 oil spills which is more
than one spill every single year also
it's not just the environment that's at
stake either there have already been red
flags that sandor production is taking a
toll on local residents researchers have
scientifically shown that areas with oil
standard production are correlated with
higher cancer rates now of course
correlation does not mean causation but
honestly the link is clear as day taking
a bigger picture view it's not just
canada's environment that would be hurt
by oil production the goal of producing
oil is to sell it to countries that need
it and when these countries use that oil
they'll be playing their own ecosystems
as well
now of course you could make the
argument that if these countries didn't
buy from canada they'll just buy from
somewhere else and that's absolutely
true
but from an ethical perspective it
wouldn't be canada that supporting said
pollution now you might be saying it how
does that change anything well the thing
to note is that canada does not need to
sell oil to do well they're already
doing well the same however cannot be
said about most middle eastern countries
that are 90 dependent on oil revenue so
it makes sense to leave the polluting to
countries that have to do it and avoid
polluting yourself especially when you
don't have to do it
in the end canada doesn't just have one
of the world's largest oil reserves but
also one of the world's most problematic
oil reserves oil sands are expensive to
extract they're super harmful for the
environment and canada doesn't have the
infrastructure to transport large
amounts of oil despite all these
obstacles it seems like canada may
actually have an opportunity to grow
their oil industry substantially in the
coming years thanks to russia as you all
probably already know it sanctioning of
available
russian oil has created a massive
as europe continues to pull back from
russia their demand for other sorts of
oil will simply continue to grow
canada's oil production is not enough to
offset russia's so canada should have
plenty of demand for their oil but if
canada is not able to build up their oil
and freight infrastructure all of that
demand will mean nothing for canada many
feel that this is actually the best case
scenario for canada they feel that there
is no reason for canada to get more
involved in the oil game just because
they have oil doesn't mean they have to
ruin their ecosystem put communities at
risk and become more dependent on oil
revenue canada already has one of the
largest economies in the world and one
of the happiest populations in the world
so why put all of that at risk just for
a bit of oil money do you guys think
canada should leverage this opportunity
with russia comment that down below
also drop a like if you're glad that
canada hasn't been corrupted by oil at
least not yet and of course consider
checking out our discord community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
subscribing and see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hurry and i'll see you guys on the next
one
you